eredità digitali è un tema
fondamentalmente che nasce dalla
consapevolezza nella quale tutti noi
viviamo oggi che esiste un insieme di
informazioni di cui in realtà non
abbiamo assolutamente la percezione
della dimensione che fanno parte di
questa nostra vita e parlo di tutti
coloro che sono viventi in questa in
questo periodo storico quindi non chi è
nato tra una data piuttosto che l'altra
è che tutti i giorni contribuiamo ad
alimentare chi più o meno consciamente
chi più o meno con etica o prendiamo
questo insieme di informazioni enormi
dalle quali siamo pienamente consapevoli
del fatto che noi attingiamo ma che
quando non ci saremo più sarà quel luogo
deputato a tramandare quei valori e
quelle informazioni appunto che
inevitabilmente influenzeranno gli stili
di vita di chi verrà dopo di noi quindi
le loro scelte di acquisto
oggi tutti i business model moderni sono
fondati su questa cosa cioè come
attraverso la gestione di questa enorme
mole di informazioni
noi compreremo casa sceglieremo dove i
nostri figli andranno a studiare e
quindi modificheremo la società nella
quale viviamo eredità digitali ed è
esattamente questo
per farlo vi chiedo di partecipare
attivamente a questi dieci minuti di
talk e vi chiedo di non spaventarvi per
i primi due in realtà
vi farò tre domande in tutto nell'arco
di questo tempo la prima è l'obiettivo è
quello di stimolare delle di
collegamenti
vi chiedo di alzare la mano se io
pronuncio le parole muro di berlino
e se a voi queste parole mi fanno
ritornare alla mente un'informazione non
importa di che natura sia cioè quanto
conosciate la storia muro di berlino
esiste dentro di voi siete il cento per
cento
fantastico
io avevo 12 anni quando è successo
quella cosa che purtroppo il mio ricordo
legato a quelle vinto lo vedete impresso
adesso sullo schermo ed è abbastanza
traumatico questa domanda non ve la
faccio chissà che cosa sta per succedere
però vi ho portato uno spezzone perché
ai 12 anni
guardi michael knight è molto bello e
utile verificare la fisica che non è
così
ciao steve jobs attenta
che per ricordare il fatto storico del
muro di berlino nel servizio e l'ho
mandato in via satellite
questo è quello che si inserisce il
significato di una variabile invece
ripresa di questo storico di qui
evidentemente tutti noi conosciamo il
significato l'inizio di quel cammino che
c'è soltanto la giacca che i [ __ ]
gioco viaggi
un filo
ap
e le parole ancora
qui no
va bene
allora non ve lo faccio vedere tutto
parole
il risparmio alla fine del video
due razzi incendiari che cercano di
posizione è una cosa realmente accaduta
cioè se volete lo possiamo lasciare
io ci parlo eccolo qua
beh
un applauso a lui per favore quello che
ha fatto questa cosa
ero al tongues a bermi una birra con
emanuele
una sera qualunque fuori c'erano nanni
eva e altri amici e mi ricordo che gli
stavo raccontando di un fatto di cui
avevo chiesto conferma un amico non
storico di politica internazionale
la domenica prima a pranzo a casa mia e
di mia mamma famiglia allargata quindi
con amici di un fa dion di un fatto che
ruta mi aveva raccontato sul su questa
cosa qua portandomi in università a
conan è dicendomi mi ricordo il giorno
che mia nonna preso me e mia sorella per
le mani e ci ha detto andiamo
venite usciamo e ci ha vestito con tutti
i vestitini tradizionali nostri dealer e
io mi ricordo di quella cosa lì che
siamo uscite in strada io ci avevo
quella corona quella coronali c'eravamo
tutti che sensori touch eravamo tutti e
tutti
il 23 agosto del 1989 due milioni di
persone sono scese in strada
nello stesso momento si sono prese per
mano e hanno coperto una distanza che
andava dal confine sud est della polonia
fino al nord del var e mal tico per 600
km 2 mesi e mezzo prima che crollasse il
muro di berlino e hanno dichiarato
pacificamente la loro indipendenza dall
occupazione
scusate questo fatto storico che
probabilmente è una variabile dirompente
nel fatto che oggi noi abbiamo un'europa
unita perché avveniva quando la cortina
di ferro esisteva ancora
e i media non ne hanno parlato così
tanto lo trovate su internet ho trovato
queste foto letto è evidente che è una
variabile storica piccolissima ma che
rende oggi che la condivido con voi ed
umani che voi la condividerete con
qualcun altro completamente un altro
impatto un altro scenario
questa cosa delle variabili e importante
c'entra tantissimo con quello di cui mi
occupo invece perché a nella biblioteca
del design di milano c'è la collezione
permanente accessibile al pubblico più
importante sulla storia del design
italiano dei primi del novecento oggi
c'è stato un periodo in questa nazione
nel quale chi stava ricostruendo da zero
quella che sarebbe stata la nostra
eredità quella che noi abbiamo ricevuto
pensava negli stessi termini di
innovazione nei quali si pensa oggi
quando non hai niente lo stimolo è
altissimo
ventimila volumi purtroppo cartacei
il progetto di digitalizzazione ha
l'obiettivo di presentato expo delle
start up dell'anno scorso abbiamo
cominciato a digitalizzare il 2 di
ottobre
oggi siamo arrivati alle prime 100.000
pagine ha l'obiettivo di distribuire
gratuitamente ai 100 migliori atenei di
architettura e design della comunità
europea l'accesso a questo database per
un totale di 100 mila studenti che
studiano design che significa progetto e
che progettano la loro vita e quella che
sarà la nostra vita di domani 2 milioni
e quasi 500.000 pagine di per testo se
una mole di dati che sono piccolissimi
pensando a quel magma di informazione di
cui parlavamo prima
ma che hanno la capacità il potere di
restituire un equilibrio al fatto che la
rete esiste da vent'anni e quello che
abbiamo generato in termini di contenuto
originale esiste da pochissimo rispetto
a quello che noi come italiani abbiamo
dato alla storia del design mondiale ha
come abbiamo influenzato la vita degli
altri
inevitabilmente quella bambina con
quella treccia lì che a quella corona in
testa che avete visto nella prima slide
e la direttrice del design center di
kaunas university of technology
principale partner di progetto di
digital design library e luogo fisico
nel quale verranno conservati questi
dati da cui poi daremo accesso a tutte
le università
la domanda che vi voglio fare adesso
per concludere e che dà un senso tutto
ciò
è condividere con voi la consapevolezza
che ogni volta che mandiamo un messaggio
con whatsapp a qualcuno che ci sta
aspettando a casa o pubblichiamo
qualcosa sulla nostra pagina di facebook
o abbiamo accesso a queste straordinarie
smart technologies
stiamo contribuendo a generare un
contenuto per quella per quella cosa che
domani sarà il nostro lascito avere
questa consapevolezza significa avere
anche la consapevolezza che ogni giorno
in ogni piccolo gesto siamo in grado di
generare una variabile distruttiva per
tutto ciò che invece viene immesso
quotidianamente su quella rete
distruttiva nel senso positivo
prendetemi nel senso costruttivo del
termine
vi faccio l'ultima domanda e poi vi
lascio quanti di voi sanno che cosa è
successo
il 23 agosto del 1989 mercoledì mattina
nei tre stati baltici alzare la mano per
cortesia
lo so che sembra stupida come domanda
però ancora un po
siamo partiti al cento per cento su
tiratela su quello appena raccontata la
storia su su su bravissimi è così
grazie di essere parte di questa storia